so we talked on the channel before about
Turing machines is this Universal model
of computation that can calculate
basically anything that a computer can
do and today I want to talk about a
different model of computation my
favorite model of computation which is
counter machines
so should we do a bit of a recap just
briefly of what a turing machine is and
then we can sort of see the counter
Machine by comparison our turing machine
if you remember has this infinite tape
divided into individual
cells something like that and on that
tape you can have any symbols written
typically we'll go over a zero on one
alphabet so we could have something one
zero zero zero one one and then there is
this old-fashioned tape head that moves
across the tape
um reading and writing to the tape
and with these instructions say if I'm
in a particular state so you have some
internal configuration and you can then
move either to the left read or write
whatever symbol is there move to the
left and so on according to these
instructions
so that's gives us quite a lot of
computing power and it was shown that
you can actually compute anything that
you want to compute basically with a
turing machine and we've not found any
computational
devices so far that can outperform a
turing machine so what is a counter
machine so in a counter machine we get
rid of the tape completely
and instead we have
these individual counters
which you can think of as air bags that
you can't really look into and into each
of those bags
you can place
a counter and your operations here
rather than reading and writing are that
you can add a counter you can subtract
counter
and you can check whether or not there
is anything in that counter you're not
able to count beyond that you can add
things in
you can reach in and you can take things
out and you can feel around that there
is nothing in it but you're not allowed
to peek inside and think oh there's 27
counters in there okay and part of the
reason for that is that that is itself a
computational task of you know imagine
there was like three billion things in
there you can't do that as an
instantaneous operation
so at first you see these and you think
this seems like it's not a very strong
model of computation it feels like a
turing machine which has this ability
for you to write down anything go back
read it gives you so much more power
than you have from just simple moving
Pebbles around between different
counters what I want to hopefully show
you today is that this is just as
powerful as a turing machine and
therefore because a chewing machine can
compute anything that a modern computer
can make so too can a counter machine
also compute pretty much anything to
build up to that though we're going to
have to start off slow and then see if
we can build up to the full power of a
turing machine let's start off very
simply what's the Hello World of
counters then the hello world of
counters is okay let's say I've got and
gets a few different colors here do the
colors matter or is that just for you
colors are just for keeping them
separate no internal meaning to this
let's call these C1 C2 and C3
now the simplest operation we can do is
to reset a counter so say we want to
reset counter one well if our only
operations are to add one counter take
one counter away or check if it's empty
how do I
zero out counter well easy enough I take
a counter away
check that it's not empty take another
counter away check that it's not empty
take another counter away oh it's empty
so we can just do this in a bit of a
loop if we were to draw that
the diagram might need a bit more paper
so we can have our initial starting
State and then what we can say is in a
loop I'm going to take my contents of my
first counter and I'm going to subtract
one from that and I'm going to keep
doing that again and again
until
my C1 is
empty which I'll do with a little
question mark there so
check every time and you kind of get
stuck in this Loop until finally we are
able to escape the loop because my
calendar is empty and then I can leave
it reminds me a little bit of a state
machine diagram is it similar very much
like a state machine which I think
you've also talked about before so
unlike the state finite State automata
there's machines without memory the
labels on the edges there are about what
the inputs are and when you get to 25 I
put it inside a double circle which is
the convention whereas here they're
telling us what is the machine doing
what are the operations of the machine
so this is probably the simplest thing
take think something away continue doing
that until the counter is empty
we can build up some slightly more
complex ones so if I want to
add two counters together so say I want
to add the contents of C1 together with
the counters of C2
and let's also say where we want this to
to go to as well so let's make sure
we're putting into C1
that's the easiest way of working out
where this is because ultimately we're
going to end up destroying the contents
of one of the counters when we do this
so if you were to think about how would
you do this if you were just playing
around with these Pebbles how would you
add the contents of C2 into the count
contents of C1 you would take them out
and put them in it right one at a time
yeah exactly so what we could do is we
could subtract one from counter C2
and
add one to sound C1 and then we just
keep doing that one at a time
and obviously checking where the C2 is
empty right yep and at some point we're
going to find that we run out of
count as we go to do the operation again
and find actually there's nothing left
in the counter and by time we've gone
through that Loop we'll find that we
have moved all the counters from C2
across to C1 and have essentially added
those two together
so pictorially we can say we're in some
particular state
we're going to
take something from C2
add it to C1 I'm going to keep doing
this
until our counter C2 is empty and that's
our very simple thing we can add two
counters together we have in the process
of this destroyed the contents of C2 so
if we need that value remaining then
we're going to have to do some other
operations to essentially copy that into
some other temporary store before doing
this operation
and to copy we can again do something
quite similar
so if I do another one which is going to
be
copy
let's put all of our counters C2 back
and let's copy the counters from C2
and put them into
C4
let's get enough of these as in advance
okay so in this case let's start in some
particular State we can't count the
contents of C2 and this thing oh I know
I need
four of these because imagine if C2 had
27 billion counters in there you can't
instantaneously look and see how many do
I need so whatever we're doing we're
going to need to make sure that we're
removing Counts from C2
and so to do that we're going to have to
you know the naive approach here is well
I could take one of these away add one
there take one of these away add one
there and so on
and all we've done here is we've moved
the copy the count the contents of the
counter
and we've kind of lost
that information we could just keep
moving these backwards and forwards so
if we want to do this we're going to
need to be a little bit more clever
and let's add one additional counter
down here which I'll just call T which
can be our temporary counter or C5 if
you prefer and what we're going to do
here is
let's go with one more color
it's a good thing I've got
a few different colors here
okay so starting off oops
with R4 here
what we're going to do is subtract a red
one and then we're going to add one
counter to C4 which is where we want it
but we're also going to add 1 into this
temporary store here
and so we can do that again move it a
red one add a dull yellow one and a nice
blue one and if we keep doing that what
we find
is that eventually
we've kind of copied the contents here
and at that point well we've got this in
this temporary store and we actually
want it back in C2 so we can then do the
same process that we had in the first
place where we remove one add one remove
one add one and we just keep doing that
in a loop
until our contents of C2 are restored
but now we've copied the contents of C2
also into C4
so let's quickly draw out what that
would look like and
so when we're doing this
was the first thing we did
we subtracted one from our C2
we added one into our contents of C4
which is where we wanted it
and then we also added one into our
temporary storage
and we just kept on doing this and our
exit from that original Loop was once
we've emptied out the counter two so
this will carry on going
and we exit when C2
is empty
and once we've fully finished that Loop
we'll have copied the counters from C2
into both C4 and our temporary storage T
but then we need to empty our temporary
storage back into C2 which we can do
with a simple Loop
this time
we subtract one from from t
and we added
back into C2
and we again continue this and I'll exit
from that Loop is do that until
T is itself empty so we can copy things
we can add things together so the next
operation that we're going to master is
can I double the contents of a counter
let's double the contents of C1 and
let's keep them in C1 so we might have
to do this movement of things into a
temporary storage and putting things
back but the overall aim is that the
contents of C1 let's start with three
there so the aim of this is at the end
of this as little mini procedure we want
to have six contents um encounter one
in our start state
what we're going to do is first of all
remove a counter from
C1 and this time we're going to make use
of our temporary storage but rather than
adding just a single counter into there
we're going to add a counter and then
add another counter
so we can do that by saying
add a counter to the temporary
add a second one to the temporary
and we're going to continue doing this
oops I missed my minus from C1
and so then we just continue this
subtract add a counter add a counter
subtract one
add a counter add a counter and we
continue that until we try and do it
again and we say oh no C1 is empty I
can't do that operation once more
so after that
C1 is empty
and we've kind of got the desired effect
here we've now got six counters but
they're in the wrong place so we can do
the same trick that we did before we
take one from the temporary storage and
we add it back
to C1 so in Reverse we take one away
add one back take one away
add one back and we should hopefully
have six counters at the end okay so if
we want to half the value of a counter
what will we do well we know how to
double a counter with this operation of
subtracting one from one counter and
adding it to another
now we can do that a same setup
but rather than subtract one counter
from
from counter one we can subtract two and
add one into the temporary storage and
then subtract two and then add one to
the temporary storage and when we do
that we'll find that we've accumulated
half of the amount that we subtracted
okay question yes the odd numbers odd
numbers exactly so what you'll have
spotted here is that when we're doing
this Loop this works perfectly fine if
we've got an even number because we can
make an even number of these cycles and
then everything works out perfectly if
we have an odd number say we're doing
three then we'll subtract one subtract
one add one to T down to one then we
subtract one and then we try and
subtract that last remaining one we've
got a problem we can't subtract we can't
have negative counters I can't
physically pull a glass counter from
thin air
so we can have another out of this point
for what happens if I have a remainder
of one
and you can then do one of two things
you can either say go back to this
same position and say well modulo you
know that whatever that one remainder is
we can take the quotient when we divide
by two
and this will work exactly the same
we'll end up
disregarding that one counter and have
the quotient when you divide by two
but if we wanted to keep hold of that
remainder then we could do something by
incrementing a third counter at this
point we just insert something into this
oh I know that I've got a remainder of
one at this point what do you want me to
do with it you could
store that somewhere okay so we can add
things we can double numbers half the
value of a counter and you can probably
work out yourself if I wanted to do
something like triple this or quadruple
this you'd go through very much the same
sequence of results but rather than just
adding two counters you'd add three or
five or wherever and still it seems like
this is fairly rudimentary computations
how can you simulate a turing machine
with just moving Pebbles around with
that we're going to need to think how do
I capture the information that's stored
in a turing machine
inside some counters
so imagine we've got this number written
on our tape imagine we're using without
loss of generality ones and zeros and
what we're going to do is kind of split
this into imagine taking a snapshot of
your turing machine
and splitting this into three pieces
we've got everything that's to the left
of the tape head
we've got everything that is to the
right of the tape head and we've got the
thing which is where the tape head is
and so what we're going to do is use our
counters to store a representation of
what's stored on the tape
and making use of the fact that we're
using binary
um ones and zeros means we can think
okay well
what if I take this 1 0 and think of
that as
a binary number one zero that would be
equal to
two
a little suffix there to mean working in
binary let's now for our second counter
let's record whatever the value of the
tape head is which is either going to be
zero and one but we can use a designated
counter for that so here we're going to
have the zero
in binary which is still zero
and for the right hand side we're going
to flip it around so we want to try and
make sure that the things that are
closest to the tape head are your least
significant bits and they get double as
they go along so this number if we flip
that around
we'll have one one zero
and binary which in this case is going
to be six what would that look like we
would have two counters in C1 and we
would have six counters one two three
four five six counters in C3 and our
counter for uh C2 will be empty and so
what we now are going to try and work
out is how do I first of all move the
tape head left and right
so if I were to have this as my
configuration and my instruction told me
move the tape head one square to the
right
what would that look like as changing
the contents of these counters and
hopefully we'll see that when we do that
the operations that has on the counters
are things that we've already seen that
we can do so moving the tape head one
square to the right
would now place it
in this position
and so this time
this would be what the we need to put
into counter one
this zero is now going to be what's
going to be encounter two so no change
is going to be needed there and this
value here
is what's going to be needed in counter
three
so
let's first look at C1
so C1 now rather than having just two
counters we need one zero zero in binary
which is four
and some of the viewers will spot that
well all we've done there is essentially
a bit shift everything's shifted over by
one binary position which is effectively
the same as just multiplying the counter
by two and luckily what we've seen we
can do already
is we have a procedure that allows us to
double the value of counter
um from any value to whatever its double
is similarly this value here was six and
now
we want it to go to
1 1 which is again this um bit shift by
one binary place which gives us three
and again we know that we can half the
value of a counter using this slightly
more complicated Loop and get down from
six to three very conveniently I've
chosen this number here so that I don't
have to worry about the awkwardness of
well what if some of these numbers here
are one we can work out what we need to
do with that because we're storing the
value of the counter in this counter
here C1 so if for example
this
was rather than a zero this was
originally a one
so that would have been
a one encounter two
now when we move our tablet across
rather than this going to one zero zero
this would now go to one zero one
because we've got that original symbol
underneath the tape head
so rather than four
we're gonna have five
so somehow it's not just a case of
doubling we also want to double and add
the contents of whatever was stored in
counter two originally
and luckily for us we know how to add
counters from one to another and we've
got a similar situation with the right
hand side if this number here wasn't a
zero but instead was a one
well what we're essentially doing is
this new number that we get here would
be essentially the remainder would be
the remainder once we divide this number
by two
this part here would become
the quotient and this part here would be
the remainder modulo 2.
and those are operations that we can do
with our halving mechanism we just need
to make sure that depending on where we
exit that first Loop if it's an even
number I don't need to do anything I
just keep counter to empty whereas if
I've only get halfway around that Loop
then I'm going to have the remainder of
one what can I do with that well I just
pop that into counter two and we're done
so all in all if I say I want to move to
the right then for our counter C1 what
we want that to be
is
doubled what it previously was so I
double
C1 but then I also want to add
our contents of C2 and in the process of
doing that we don't mind destroying the
contents of C2 because it's being moved
it's become part of that become part we
can forget about it at that point
so even if it's a zero it doesn't matter
anyway does it right exactly if it's a
zero adding it on is not going to do
anything we'd essentially be
in the process of doing our addition
Loop and it would just say oh I can't do
the loop at all go straight to finishing
C2 that was the part where we just take
the remainder of
um the contents of C3
when we divide by two so in Python that
is the remainder and you divide by two
and for C3 well that is going to be the
value of C3 I take the quotient when I
divide by two so
sometimes to note that with the double
backslash just forget about the
remainder just halve it essentially
and exactly the same works symmetrically
if we wanted to know how to move to the
left we just essentially do this
fully symmetrically C3 we would be
doubling and adding on the cap contents
of C2
C2 would be the same but it would be the
remainder of C1 because that's what's
being pushed into that counter at that
point and C1 would be the one where we
are halving it and forgetting about its
remainder and so with those operations
we can move to the left we can move to
the right we can read and write whatever
the symbol is that's underneath the tape
head and those are the easiest
operations essentially
because if I want to
write a zero
well all I need to do at that point is
reset whatever counter two is so if it's
a zero keep it as a zero if it's a one
reset it to zero so that was our very
first that was our hello world of
counters
I just reset
down to two
and you can probably predict if I wanted
to write one well the easiest operation
the easiest way to do this is to First
reset it to zero and then just add one
so this can be reset C2
and then just increment it by one so
those are right operations on move
operations and our read operations are
really down to looking what is in our
our C2 counter and it should only ever
be zero or one and it should only ever
be zero or one so exactly we can always
just look at that and we have to be a
little bit careful in the case that it's
one if it's zero we've got an operation
which is oh check that it's not empty if
it's one we can't look and say oh I can
see that that value is one we can only
do that by taking you know and trying to
remove something from it and one way to
do that so if I had a counter in our C2
I can't just look and say oh I can see
that there's one there the only thing I
can do is subtract one
add it to a temporary counter just so
it's stored somewhere and then I can
check oh yep I know I'm not empty I must
have had one there originally
but you still want to have the counter
there so you just do this press the
remove in Reverse remove account from
there and add it
back where you want it so
with these simple operations you can end
up simulating exactly what you would do
with a turing machine so if you were to
give me a turing machine program what I
would do is with quite a lot of you know
little mini circuits and subroutines I
could recreate a counter machine that
would behave exactly or analogously to
how your turing machine is working and
since you can compute pretty much
anything you want on a turing machine
then with a counter machine might take
you a few more steps and a lot of glass
beads but eventually you'd be able to
compute whatever you wanted to with just
these
that gets you there or want to and when
you get to 25 I'll put it inside a
double circle which is the convention
because that's the finished date you've
I'm going to utilize prime
factorizations so the number that we're
going to store into this first counter
we're going to say